-I'm hanging out
with Kieran Culkin now.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Kieran, the big thing that fans
love about "Succession" is
all of the iconic quotes,
insults, and one-liners
from you and your castmates,
so we wanted
to put your knowledge
to the test in a game we call
"Who Said It?"
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tell who said it ♪
♪ Tell me who said it, yeah ♪
-Alright, here we go.
Here's how it works.
I'm going to read you
real quotes from "Succession,"
could be any character
from any season,
and you have to tell me
who said it.
Sound okay?
-[ Blowing raspberry ]
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
Quote is...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's good.
Gerri?
No. Who is it?
-Let's see who said it.
-Tom, you need to shut up.
This isn't the time to get
your conscience out and shout,
"Hey, look at me.
I cannot tell a lie.
I'm a good little boy.
Look at my ding-dong."
-There you go.
[ Ding ]
That's right. It is Gerri.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That is correct.
[ Rimshot ]
Okay.
Here's this quote...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow, that's tough.
Wow, that's good.
Hugo?
I don't know.
-Let's see who said it.
-You don't really hear much
-Oh!
-about syphilis, these days.
Pretty much the --
the MySpace of STDs.
-[ Laughs ] Very good delivery.
[ Buzzer ]
That was Tom!
[ The Roots play sad trombone ]
That was Tom. Am-wah.
Alright. Here we go.
Here's a quote here...
-Is there more?
-No.
-That's cousin Greg.
-Let's see.
-That's the one rule
on these things, man.
Teak deck?
No shoes.
-Uh, what if --
what if your toenails
are not all that
aesthetically pleasing?
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You called it.
Good delivery.
-He's great.
-He's hilarious.
-Alright, but this quote.
Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-I mean, that's like, I feel
like a carful of people,
but, yeah,
let's go with Kendall.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Bad tweet!
-I got it, I got it, I got it!
Bad tweet!
-Kendall Roy
is not a hero.
-Bad tweet!
[ Ding ]
-That's right. Correct!
-I watch the show!
[ Rimshot ]
-Correct!
-I watch it.
-Alright.
Who said...?
[ Laughter ]
Let's see right here.
-♪ Your friend
doesn't like you ♪
♪ Boo-hoo, boo-hoo ♪
♪ And Dad wants to fire you ♪
♪ Woo-hoo, woo-hoo ♪
-That's right. Correct!
[ Ding ]
[ Rimshot ]
Kieran Culkin, everybody!
"Succession"
airs Sunday nights on HBO.
You can check Kieran out
tomorrow night
on "Saturday Night Live"
with Ed Sheeran.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Congratulations.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break, everybody.
Break a leg!
-Thank you.